Michael Henretty - VoiceHTML - Speech Recognition
as a Progressive Enhancement.
Alright.
Cool, thanks, everyone for showing up today.
I appreciate your coming out and hearing about
voice.
I work for Mozilla.
I'm a web engineer.
These days, I work on Open Innovation, and
I will talk about that in a second.
The project I'm working on is called Common
Voice, which is Mozilla's initiative to crowd
source a large set of data voices to be used
in speech technology.
We're trying to solve the data problem for
machine learning and voice.
We're currently working on multiple languages
meaning languages other than English.
If you're interested in collecting speech
data for your language, reach out to me.
I have some contact info there.
Today, we're going to talk about voice HTML,
the web and app stores.
We're going to do a brief history of the web,
and then get into my VoiceHTML proposal, like
I promised, and then a case study on booking
a flight with VoiceHTML.
I will try to get into Q&A if we have time
for that.
Disclaimers.
I hate doing them but I will need to this
time.
If you read the pitch, the pitch that I gave
you was more of click bait to get people here
interested in voice and interested in the
internet.
I made some bold statements there that I'm
going to propose a new protocol and propose
a case study on the protocol.
It might not be the protocol you might think.
This is not a technical talk.
I'm not going to release a library or an API.
This is going to be more about trust.
I hope that you will bear with me as we talk
about this today, because this is maybe a
little different than what you're expecting.
I hope it will be good.
VoiceHTML.
So, around the end of 2016, I had finished
my last very successful project at Mozilla
called Firefox OS - you might have heard of
it!
I moved over to the Open Innovation team.
What I was doing was trying to what Open Innovation
team does is reach out to other teams within
Mozilla and get them to be more successful
by embracing open practices.
I was working on a project called Dynotank
which is an ideas contest.
Pretty much anybody who was interested in
Dynotank can submit ideas to Dynotank and
then we have a team of executives who you
would pitch to if we like your idea, and then
the top ideas get selected to be worked on.
For working on it be we would do a week of
a design-thinking design sprint.
We would have about eight different people
from all sorts of different walks of life
and skill sets, and we would investigate the
problem and see if we can build anything there.
One of those ideas was querying the voice-enabled
internet.
How can the internet and voice play well together?
One of the concepts that came out of the design
sprint - you can see it here a bit, was VoiceHTML.
That text says, "Voice analogy of HTML allows
simple authoring of apps that can understand
speech and speak."
Everyone loved this idea.
It had by far the most votes.
Those little blue dots are votes.
We really wanted to explore this.
What I would like to do is explore the topic
of VoiceHTML by exploring what the web is,
so we're going to do like a brief history
here.
Okay.
So let's start with the web.
Why do we like it?
Why is it so great?
Why would anybody want to use the web over
competing models which we will talk about
in a second?
As a developer, the apps you make are easy
to make, they're cross-platform, you don't
have to worry about gatekeepers, there's no
revenue-sharing model or no approval process.
As a user, we love the web.
That's what we use on desktop.
Your computers are now basically browsers
with a couple of other apps.
The reason we like it is work flow.
We have multiple tabs open, we have email,
calendar, looking up concert tickets while
Wikipedia-ing things and it is seamless and
quick to get things done.
We love that we don't have to install.
And these last two points are really important.
We will talk about them and focus on them
today.
There's an established trust model for the
internet.
We know how to trust it.
We put our credit card information in there,
and our social security tax ID in there, so
we trust it.
It's taken as while to get there, and I would
like to explore that a little bit.
We have choice: there's a ton of choice on
the internet.
I can choose the device that I'm using - I
can use a desktop, a phone, I can use any
number of IOT devices.
You can choose what browser, what sites you're
using.
The choice is really paramount to what the
web is.
Okay, but, the web is not the only model that
is extremely successful right now.
There are other models out there, and I think
we need to examine a little bit.
Because, with all these great things, why
would anyone choose anything different?
Let's look at it.
App stores: that's the other big model, right?
An app store, love it or hate it, they're
extremely successful, and actually pretty
nice.
Let's talk about why they're nice: as a developer,
the SDK and the IPA moves fast.
There's no consensus needed.
A single group of people can decide and a
lot of people follow suit.
That's good as a developer because things
move very quickly.
I don't know if any of you are iOS developers
but you get a lot of updates and it's very
exciting.
Next, you have a direct channel to your users.
You know exactly where they are because there's
only one place they can be.
It's not like the web.
Then performance: you can optimise specifically
for your platform much easier than this kind
of cross-platform that we love about the web.
As a user now, why do users like app stores?
There's an easy trust model.
I can trust that app store and everything
that comes out of that app store, I can trust.
The other day, I had to make a meme picture
I sent to my family, and I went and downloaded
five apps from the app store.
I didn't care or worry about it, I just did
it.
Whether or not that's a good thing, it is
nice as a user not to have to think about
what I'm visiting and what I'm doing.
Also, the content is curated and tailored
more me, and also for the store.
I generally like the stuff that comes up,
the stuff that surfaced to the top of the
app store, of app stores.
Then of course performance.
I love performance.
The web is great, it's moving along, but it
doesn't hold a candle to a native app.
If you're making a video game, which I used
to do in a former life, you wouldn't do the
web, unfortunately.
You wouldn't use HTML/5.
You can, but you're getting difficulty getting
to the same level as an app, as an app is
with default.
There is a third value pool that we need to
talk about: the owner of that place.
There is no owner of the web.
There are owners of app stores, and, of course,
they love it because they get 30 per cent.
That's their standard cut.
Also, they get to control the experience for
their users.
They need to show exactly what they see.
They can limit competition.
If you compete with a business model of someone
who owns an app store, they're not going to
let you into that app store.
This is really important.
So we've talked a little bit about the difference
between Web and app stores.
Let's talk about where this competition came
from, and we're going to take a journey back
in time.
We will start with 2007.
Steve Jobs.
Let me just say it: we went native third-party
applications on the iPhone.
You may not remember, before this time, before
he said this, the web was dominant on mobile.
Even on iPhone.
The iPhone existed before the app store.
There were a lot of reasons why the web was
a great killer app for phones especially because
of Steve Jobs, actually.
He added a lot of these features you see here
- GPS and maps, he did that, actually.
He made it really good.
You can make phone calls.
If you see a phone number, you can make a
phone call.
You can add things to your home screen, like
book marking to your home screen.
That was a new concept.
And then this pinch-to-zoom double tap, it
was a way to use desktop web pages on your
phone.
At the time, there were other phones that
were smartphones that had the web, and they
weren't a great experience.
In the early days, Steve Jobs was really bullish
about the mobile web.
When he released the iPhone, he said this:
what is the developer story?
We've got the web, baby.
We've got Safari, the best mobile browser
out there.
He had a reason to be optimistic.
It had a great SDK and tooling already.
You already had documentation.
You already had this vast distribution platform,
you had content discovery figured out.
So it's a no-brainer.
Then he beat all of the existing browsers
that were out there.
Look at the Blackberry versus his phone.
This was a similar time.
He had touch versus scroll wheel, double-touch,
bigger screens and incredible performance.
For a while, the web was the killer app on
the phones.
How long was that?
Let's look: June 2007, he said, 2.0 applications,
and then, October 2007, native app store.
That's about three months where the web was
amazing on phones.
But it was a great time.
But however, the iPhone was not the first
smartphone.
There were other phones that were around before
the iPhone, and the web was a killer app.
You had the world's knowledge in your pocket.
You had transactions; you had vast communities
discussing various niche topics.
You had to have it on your phone.
Why wasn't it a killer app?
We have to look at that?
We have to go back to 1995, the boom of the
internet, this is where everything happened.
One year.
It is amazing.
We had JavaScript, Ruby, PHP, all released
1.0, that year.
Internet explorer, Opera, Amazon, the first
Wiki web, the first WYSIWYG editor for HTML,
and then the first computer wiretaps.
That's pretty important.
Phones were rudimentary at this time but they
had the web.
You can see over here there is in Nokia, the
first phone that had internet capabilities
on, email check and map functionality.
It was a huge boon for phones.
Why is this good?
The web had trust figured out.
I could put my credit card in the web at this
time.
I could make payments.
Amazon was around, or Amazon became around
because of that.
Then discovery.
Discovery is a really important and difficult
concept when you're trying to make a distribution
platform.
The web did it really well.
Let's say I wanted to look up my favourite
move, You've Got Mail.
How would I do that?
I would search for it.
If we talk about search and where it came
from, there's only one company we ever need
to talk about, right?
Infoseek!
The year before, Infoseek came round and revolutionised
search.
They did real time search updates, and they
did cost-per-click ads which changed the game,
and behavioural targeting which also changed
the game.
They also did pop-ups.
Unfortunately, Google came around about three
years later and crushed them.
And, for a number of reasons, we won't talk
about it, and I don't even know all those
reasons, but this had a lasting effect on
the internet.
Later, this site would break up, become go.com,
and Baidu came out of this knowledge, and
it had a huge effect on the internet.
Search.
What did people do before search?
How did they find content?
Let's look.
It's stuff like this.
Directories, and portals.
All these links grouped together.
This was the original vision of the internet
- link the document content.
It was great because you could find things
that you were looking for and you had a quick
search type-thing but this is not the search
as we know it today.
You literally crawled the internet to find
what you were looking for.
People loved it, although, at the time, nobody
would put their credit card into this.
So the trust on the internet didn't come overnight.
So, is this little thing here, is this the
killer app for phones in 1992 when this was
around?
No.
Phones were the killer of the internet back
then.
You picked this thing up, and it would kill
whatever you were downloading at that time.
The phones and the internet didn't play together
in the early days.
A lot of that had to do with the trust.
There wasn't any trust established with how
you might transact on the internet.
It was a shared document for.
Why is that important?
Why is the shared document store even anything
worth talking about?
Let's go back one more step, last step.
This is Tim Berners-Lee.
This was his executive summary of the World
Wide Web.
He said this project was started with a philosophy
that as much academic information should be
freely available to anyone no matter where
they are in the world.
This is the idea.
He wasn't thinking about payments; he wasn't
thinking about discovery.
He was thinking that information should be
spread to everyone.
So, I think that, if we talk about what we
like about the internet, and how voice should
work on the internet, I really like this as
a kind of visionary piece.
Okay.
So now we've taken a brief history of the
internet, just random one, actually.
I'm supposed to propose a new protocol of
voice, right?
That's what I came here to do.
I would like to do that.
I'm going to do that but I need a moment to
talk about something first.
And that is trust.
So, if you will just trust me for a minute,
we're going to do some pictures, and we're
going to talk about how trust works on the
internet, or with technology in general.
Let's start with Tim Berners-Lee, 1991, no
internet.
In the early days, this was, this might have
been the computer that TBL himself was using.
It's six for us to understand and easy for
us to trust.
You see this brief case here with money?
This is a metaphor, and it what it relates
to is personal data.
I like to put money in data because it's intrinsically
linked.
Money isn't the only reason why you should
- let's say that money - let's start with
money.
If you have money, you want to protect it
in this brief case, so you need to put it
somewhere safe.
You can see there is this blue hazy cloud
around the brief case.
That blue hazy cloud represents trust.
Think time you have money, you need to trust
where it is, right?
We are going to use the blue cloud to talk
about how these different models work, right?
We had this computer, right?
You had your spreadsheet, your tax information,
maybe finance and bank records, and games.
But where would you get those games?
How would you install an app in this time?
Let's do another diagram.
So this is how we would do it: you would physically
I get in your car probably with your family,
you would go to a store, brick and mortar
app store, and you would purchase it, and
you would be very happy, and you would come
home.
You will notice that there is a trust cloud
around this store.
That's pretty important here because the software
you buy from them, you better had trust there,
right, because you're about to install it
on your computer.
However, the nice thing was, and the reason
we trusted it was because we knew how stores
worked, we understood that trust model, and
we got our computer and the software from
the same place, and we got our computer fixed
from the same place.
There was a little bit of conflict of interest
there, but we could trust that.
We thought they were experts, and all this
software that surfaced, we assumed that's
the software that was out there.
We didn't think there was stuff outside of
this.
This is easy for us to understand.
You notice, and this is something that is
pretty important, is, for both of these trust
clouds, you also have a choice.
You can choice to go to Micro Center or other
store, choose to use IBM, Apple, any number
of computers back in the day.
You had a choice.
Without this choice, there's really not trust.
The trust is an active thing, at least to
me.
If you talk about what trust is without choice,
it is more like hope, because you don't have
a choice.
Trust is you're choosing to trust the things
that you choose.
Okay.
Well, I just - I love this picture because
it is like the feeling I had whenever I go
to Microsoft.
Or whenever I go to Micro Center.
I knew some cool stuff was happening.
So let's talk about the trust model for the
internet.
This is much more complex, right?
This is what Tim Berners-Lee had in mind.
You notice the first thing I want to talk
about - on the left here - calling it the
user agent, and it is your browser.
There's this whole new trust model that had
to form around the browser.
This is like your gatekeeper to the internet,
right?
It's what all the information flows through.
It is separate from the content.
It is not all grouped together like this.
We had to learn about what a browser is.
We had to learn how to trust our browsers,
and, then, on the other side of this, you
have a bunch of websites which are all constantly
under construction, constantly changing.
We had to learn to trust each of those individually
or not trust them.
We understand this now, right?
This is ten or 15 years later - 30 years later.
We understand.
We also had this middle part which we're not
going to talk about but it is pretty interesting.
You have like these dump trucks of information,
right?
That's the Information Superhighway, and,
in the middle, there is this magic.
There is complexity there, there is trust.
There are a lot of things to discuss: you
have the ISPs, backbones, government regulation.
But, for the normal everyday use of installing
or using content, you don't think about that,
right?
It's all hidden for you.
Your user agent brokers all that.
This is a really cool, this is a really cool
breakdown because you get trust, so many granular
choices of trust, and then this user agent
over here, it doesn't care what content you
see.
It just wants to make sure what you see that
content that you have a good experience while
doing it.
This is a disinterested third-party in what
you're doing or using this platform for.
This is pretty important to how trust works
on the internet.
Let's work on the app store model.
Here's the Apple app store.
And despite the fact that we put this in jail,
so we're trying to lead a little bit, users
actually love this model because you have
a single source of trust.
You just use this software, this phone, this
app store, and everything is kind of taken
care for you, right?
Of course, there are bad parts about being
locked in.
The developers there, you have to make sure
that you're part of this ecosystem, but users
love this.
This is a very popular successful model.
But it is not the way things have to work.
Okay.
Promised to talk about voice, didn't I?
Let's talk about voice.
We don't really is have an established trust
models around voice yet.
We need to.
We are starting to formulate one, and it's
looking a lot more like the app store model,
and it's looking like the internet.
It is because it's much easier to trust the
product you buy into your house but look at
all these new data types.
Like, you have your speech, you have the type
of music you listen to, you have control over
your house, and data about your house - your
locks, lights, your habits.
You have your ambient noise.
All sorts of stuff here that is really a little
bit scary, but you have to choose to trust
all of it or nothing.
That's where it is right now.
That's kind of just the tip of the iceberg.
There are all these processes that go on underneath
from the people who own these platforms that
we don't know about, right?
I'm a big fan of Google, Amazon, and Apple
- I use their products all the time - but
it is always good to be a little bit sceptical
about what we are using and try to understand
how could this data be used?
How might they be using this data?
Okay.
So, I promised to propose a new API for the
web.
But you've probably seen by now we've talked
mostly about trust more than the web, more
than any sort of technology.
We're going to continue that but I'm going
to propose a new protocol.
It might not be what you think.
Okay, so, VoiceHTML: I said in my pitch a
new protocol for how voice assistance could
interact with websites.
I had better propose this right.
Any time you introduce a new protocol on the
internet, you can't do it really fast, right?
I could go and have the best protocol right
now, but if there is no consensus around it,
nobody's going to use it.
You have to break it down into phases, and
I've broken it down into four phases for you
all.
Bear with me as we go through this.
Phase 1, central screenreader day.
What if, for once a year, all you could use
the internet was using a screenreader, right?
We could get all the top browsers come together
and decide on a certain day, you can't use
the internet except through a screenreader.
[Single whoop from the audience.].
There are a couple of reasons we want to do
this.
I'm actually not a browser vendor.
I don't represent Mozilla, so I hope - I mean,
I do represent them, but I don't talk about
Firefox, I talk about voice, so I can't do
this myself.
We have to do this together.
The benefits here are more than getting voice
better on the internet.
We have more empathy from users than developers.
People will understand what it's like to use
the web without these great kind of cool interactive
experiences that are visual interactive experiences,
and then immediately, you will have better
accessibility.
What if we chose black Friday to have International
Screen Reader day?
People will make their sites super accessible
overnight.
Let's do it.
Any of you who are browser vendors, talk to
me.
Step two, souped up screenreaders.
We're not going to be able to take it.
It's going to be too difficult for most of
us.
We are going to have to add some functionality
to the screenreaders for this one day to make
sure we can use the internet before and be
at least somewhat productive.
Where to start?
We surveyed Amazon, Echo and Alexa users and
home users, and said what are the features
of the product that you would really like
to use?
I think that would be a great start for screenreaders.
You could do email better, if you could discover
new features and skills; if you could read
and summarise news and order food.
These are internet can already do a lot of
this stuff, right?
We have to make screenreaders have a better
experience.
What convenient readers need to do is - what
screenreaders need to do is track a little
bit of state about you and needs to be ostensible.
Then we can rely on everyone to expend, to
build a really great experience in an open
way.
Okay.
Step three: Robbie the Reader.
Robbie is your friend.
Robbie knows everything about you.
He knows that you like using Go Euro for train
trips.
He knows that you're tracking Olympic figure
skating.
He lives within your phone and speakers, and
he's always there for you.
He's like your mission control, or the person
in the chair who is always by the internet
for you.
He's like a co-pilot in life who can use the
internet.
There are a couple of things here that are
aspirational, like a conversational interface,
some sort of roaming profile that has your
data that you can still trust, a semantic
understanding of the web, and no knowledge
of how to use websites, right?
So this is interesting.
Like, instead of an API that Robbie is interacting
with, the browser is the API.
He's using the browser for you.
Most importantly, he has your trust.
Without trust, you're not going to be doing
any of the transacting you want to do on the
internet with Robbie you need that trust,
right?
Final step: disappointment.
This is not going to work for a number of
reasons.
Screenreaders are for reading screens, not
for adding some kind of personal voice assistant.
Natural language understanding, conversational
interfaces, they're still very, very hard.
We're getting there, but it's years out.
Speech-to-text, text-to-speech, those are
still hard.
That's why you only have a couple of of players
in this space.
Semantic understanding of the web, this is
moving really fast, in academia, but we're
still far away, and we didn't even talk about
monetisation apps, so it's going to be hard
to do Robbie - Robbie the Reader.
The point of this is that we don't actually
need any new protocols for the web.
Web has some great APIs already.
You have aria and the accessibility tree.
It will be great for semantic understanding.
We have the web speech API, speech synthesis
so it can understand your voice and talk back
to you.
We have real time communication channels like
web sockets, and you have JavaScript, tying
it all together.
You really have a platform we need top we
have so many things figured out.
So let's go back to our model of the internet.
This took us years and years before we trusted
this.
We learned to like this, because we learned
about choice.
This is still a prevailing model, despite
the success of app stores.
Can we bring a similar model to the internet?
The biggest change here is you see just on
the left, we have a house instead of your
computer, so there's a little bit more types
of data that are stored inside there, right?
Then you have this little speaker which is
a user agent for you.
So right now, they're not user agent where
they're vendor agents.
You buy a product, a voice product, as a representative
of that company.
Your browser actually represents you.
It is supposed to be completely independent
of the content you get from it, so we need
this sort of trust model and voice.
The protocol that I'm proposing here is not
about technology, it's about how we understand
our products, and how we use our products,
and, really, what I'm doing here today is
I want to propose a question or a problem,
and I want your help on it.
That's why I did this click bait title because
I wanted people who are architects of the
internet to talk to us about it.
We don't know the answer to this, and we're
trying to work it out right now.
The last thing that I had promised to do was
compare screenreaders versus voice HTML and
booking a flight.
VoiceHTML is vapourware, no libraries to compare
with.
No matter how difficult it is to book a flight
with a screenreader, and, trust me, it is
very difficult, but it beats HTML because
it works today.
I thought it might be interesting instead
to compare what we have today versus what
it was like before the internet.
How did we book flights before the internet?
How?
I didn't know.
I had to ask somebody.
I asked my dad!
[Laughter].
Dad said, "I would call a travel agent, and
he was paid by the hotel or airline as a percentage
of costs."
That's a conflict of interest, right?
So he would shop around.
He would look for travel agents that were
trustworthy in general.
I wasn't even asking about trust.
He brought up trust himself.
Trust is always embedded in the things we
do.
You notice there is something interesting,
this built-in conflict of interest.
These travel agents didn't represent him,
they represented the airline or hotel.
This was a vendor agent, right?
We have mechanisms in place where we can beat
that model, I think.
Okay.
So, that's what I wanted to propose: how can
we make a better future for how we might interact
with these products of the future?
Final thoughts: trust is hard, right?
But it's important.
It's what made the web successful, it's what
made app stores successful, and it is what
makes technology successful.
The web I don't think needs any new APIs for
voice - not yet.
Maybe it will as we go along.
Maybe we could extend Aria to add interaction
stuff, maybe add some new APIs for open graph
met at that tags to announce this is a vote-enabled
site and you can find it on search engines.
We can talk about that but I don't think it's
the most pressing topic right now.
What we need, what voice needs, is a new trust
model that is like the web.
We need that user agent.
So, to wrap up, my question to you, and what
I would love help with, is how are we going
to do this?
How are we going to change our models for
how we interact with these voice products?
We are the architects of the internet.
We kind of move the direction.
We have a lot of power in how these things
work.
So how can we do it?
I really don't know.
If you have thoughts, and ideas about any
of this trust, reach out to me.
This is my act information.
Also, this is our common voice project, so
you can donate your voice right now.
This will be a public data set, completely
public domain.
We make that promise to you so everything
you do is benefitting the public good.
Come and check out our website.
The team, we have a blog, Medium blog.
We talk about diversity and inclusion, open
practices, we talk about voice.
So all of those things are there.
But thank you.
This is the talk.